joining us online is matt walsh
nationally recognized writer blogger
podcaster and speaker of course he hosts
the Matt Walsh show here at the Daily
wear has a brand new book Church of
coward to wake up call to complacent
Christians is out yesterday and surging
up the charts McAdoo talked you sir hey
Ben how's it going thanks crabman hey
it's going pretty well so let's talk
about the new book obviously one of the
things that we are watching in the
United States is a radical rise in the
number of people who have declared
themselves non believing that is the
largest group of people in the
Democratic Party at this point so what
exactly has happened to church in the
United States because as church wanes
obviously secularism Rises and with it
this this seeming call for more
government intervention ISM more
liberalism what's happened to Church in
the United States yeah I think it's
worse I think it's worse even than the
statistics tell us because of the stats
tell us that there are I don't know 80
percent Christians or something like
that and that number is is is is
trending downwards but how many of them
are actually fully believing if you look
at the statistics the number of
Christians who can affirm even the most
basic doctrinal points of Christianity
that number is much lower than the 80
percent figure I think the you know
what's happening is that Christians are
religious people in general I think are
sort of drifting on the tide of the
culture and going wherever the culture
takes them
that's the complacency I talked about in
the book I think that's that's the great
challenge that we face as a church is
just this willingness this or an
unwillingness really to resist the tide
of the culture in this idea that we have
to just go along with whatever the
culture says and of course the culture
says we should be secular irreligious
faithless and that's what's happening so
why exactly is that happening so they I
was always informed you as a religious
person myself I was always informed that
the value in religion always lay in sort
of its adherence to eternal values and
standing up for principles and yet I
agree with you I mean I see it in my own
religious community this attempt to sort
of give away those eternal values in
favor of some pizza and guitar that this
belief that that religion is somehow
going to earn new converts and fill the
pews simply by giving in to the
prevailing winds of social culture you
see this in the Democratic Party with
people who judge who cites the Bible to
support pro-abortion positions for
example what why had so many churches
acquiesced in this I think I think I
think there are many reasons for it that
we could point to
maybe the fundamental issue is that
there is that that we've we focus only
on the here and now and there's a
further the focus has been in the church
generally has been making your life more
comfortable I mean the most odious
versions of that of course things like
the prosperity gospel and Joel Osteen
and that's the most explicit version but
you find versions of that and anywhere
you go it seems like we're where it's
it's about getting along with the
culture and making friends and even even
the the virtues so-called virtues that
are promoted being welcoming being
tolerant being accepting which of course
aren't virtues at all but that's all
about just getting along with people
it's a the focus is always it's not
about the eternal things it's about it's
about the here and now so how do we make
religious people less complacent because
it seems like the easiest way to move
along in our culture Matt is to is to be
complacent is to is to see tolerance as
the highest possible value and whatever
floats your boat seems to be the ethic
of the day and of course here we're
talking about the culture we're not even
talking about what government ought to
be doing we're talking about just what
you as a as a person believe is sinful
and not sinful how do we fight back
against that one the easiest path to to
being treated well in today's society is
indeed to give up some of those values
and or at least be quiet about those
values for the sake of popularity I
think we have to get back to first of
all basic questions like what is the
what is our purpose what why why do we
exist what's what's the purpose of
living I mean these are the questions
that you're supposed to go to religion
for and religion supposed to provide an
answer for the questions that religion
used to not be afraid to answer but but
but recently has been so we need to we
need there needs to be a renewed focus
on that an understanding of what our
purpose is and that's going to involve
things like I think in the church you
know calling congregants to sacrifice
there needs to be a moral message we
can't be afraid of the moral message
that's the interesting thing seems to me
about guys like Bernie Sanders you know
why does he resonate so much part of the
reason is yeah the entitlement mentality
the stupid Millennials so on and so
forth like that's that's part of it but
the other part of it is that he has a
moral message his message is all about
moral out
and all the evil things and terrible
things that are happening in the culture
I disagree with his prescriptions for it
further those four to remedy those evils
but at least he has a moral message
whereas I think for among conservatives
and Christians and we've become afraid
of making that moral point so what do
you think is the moral message of
Christianity that needs to be heard in
today's culture because the you know
you're talking to a lot of people who a
lot of people who read this book are
gonna be people who are already
committed Christians already committed
religious people but let's say you're
talking to somebody secular why should
they become a committed religious person
as opposed to simply sort of drifting
along on the on the waves here I think I
think one of the most important moral
messages is about the dignity of the
human person that we are human beings
have value that that we matter we have
dignity and you don't find that in in
the broader culture what you find in the
culture that every the things that are
celebrated in the culture the things
that degrade the human person and
nobody's really happy with that and no
one no one feels happy and I think
that's why there's so much depression
and drug use and everything and suicide
epidemic all these things are wrapped up
in it
so I I think that in that that can
obviously appeal to people that's a
message that can appeal to someone even
who's not religious that you have
dignity you have value well Matt Matt
Walsh his new book his Church of cowards
a wake up call to complacent Christians
it is out yesterday and searching up the
charts Matt really appreciate I'm going
to talk to you sir thanks man appreciate
it
I hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content